oh look at the smoker that everyone
cheat off on the test
they thought you said on a test yeah
chloe went
there on keeping up with the kardashians
we all want to be cute over here okay
the latest episode was all about how the
kardashian fam
handled quarantine and chloe was really
going through it in her final days of
battling covet 19
like fall out the bed going through it
and then there was this i made a friend
i decided to have
an imaginary friend poor tina
my new best friend i'm just getting
lonely and bored and i need someone to
keep me
company yes quarantina
chloe's very own version of wilson the
volleyball
quarantina actually is a little bit of a
gift
she led to a rare rob kardashian
sighting
so you look crazy god bless god bless
you
and this tristan moment tina
threesome what
[Music]
really tristan a threesome
crazy no i can't genuinely i cannot
believe it in all honesty this couple is
just the gift that keeps on giving
and yes chloe and tristan are back to
being a couple
in august a source told et quote chloe
is doing what
she feels is right for herself and her
daughter things with chloe and tristan
have been great and the couple is taking
this time in quarantine to really
reconnect
and enjoy one another i'm really just
enjoying my life
and my time with my baby and family
chloe and tristan's co-parenting skills
with little true were on
full display on keeping up and their
journey to get back to the good place
after that whole
you know cheating scandal
we'll play out as this season of the
show continues
has chloe slept with tristan again yes
but you know what you do you chloe
whatever makes you happy
it's such a beautiful thing
[Music]